The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Today, more games.
Last time in
general, we're going
to look at this categorization
of different types of games.
So far we've been focusing on
the one-player category, which
normally think of as
puzzles or not games at all.
But today we're going to branch
out in the other directions.
And we're going to talk about
zero-player games, which
arguably are also not
games, and two-player games.
But to fill out this
space, we probably
won't get out here yet to
EXPTIME and Undecidable games.
But we will stick to this chunk.
We're going to start
with zero-player games,
also simulations-- Game of Life
is the classic example here.
And these can be very hard,
despite being very simple
and not really
having any choices.
So as a funny equality here,
the sliding block puzzles
and things that we
looked at last time
where you have agency, you have
a choice of which move to make,
will remain PSPACE
complete even when
you don't have that choice.
This category is
not so interesting.
If you a polynomially
bounded zero-player game,
that is a computer.
And it can just compute
something for polynomial time.
And recall, this polynomially
bounded number of moves.
And this is an exponentially
Although you can actually
go a little bit higher.
And we'll talk about that
and get even harder problems
when you have potentially
infinitely many moves.
And then we'll go
into two-player,
in particular,
two-player bounded,
where we get another
PSPACE completeness result.
As you may recall from time ago,
all of these versions of games
have constraint
logic variations.
So we've focused on this one.
But I'll mention this one, and
this one, and this one today.
And they're all complete.
So we can use them
to reduce things.
But before we get
to constraint logic,
I'm going to be talking about
both more classical ways
of proving hardness
in these classes,
and then also the
constraint logic way.
And we'll start with
the Game of Life.
Let me write down a
definition of the game in case
you haven't seen it,
or if you've forgotten.
So this was invented by Conway.
'70s.
So you have two types of
cells-- living cells, which
are the black cells;
and dead cells,
those are the white cells.
And you have this iteration--
every cell in parallel updates.
In general, this is called
a cellular automaton.
And if we have a
living cell, it will
continue to live if and only
if it has two or three living
neighbors.
This is among the
eight neighbors
in the 8-way adjacency.
And then if we have
a dead cell, then it
becomes living-- it's
born, if you will-- if
and only if it has exactly
three living neighbors.
And so those are the rules.
We don't really need
to know the rules
except for verifying that
very small gadgets work.
Most of what I'll talk
about are higher level
than specifics of these rules.
But some things you
should know is sometimes
you get a periodic
pattern like this pulsar.
Sometimes you get
a static pattern.
These things don't change
because for example, on the 2
by 2 square, each
of the living cells
has exactly three neighbors.
And so it lives.
And each of the dead cells has
not exactly three neighbors.
And so I guess one or two.
And so they remain dead.
And so nothing changes.
That's called still life.
There's tons of
puns in this area.
And so that's well and good.
And so one question you might
ask is, given a pattern,
is it a still life?
Well, that's easy to check.
Is it periodic?
That's harder to check.
Does it ever die out
and become nothing?
That's actually kind of common.
And that, we will prove,
is very hard to check.
But all these
questions are related,
other than still
life, which is easy.
So some other cool things you
should know about are gliders.
Gliders are a kind
of periodic pattern,
but with a diagonal offset.
So they go off to infinity
in a diagonal direction,
unless they hit something.
Then something might happen.
But in the absence
of anything else
they'll just keep
going on for infinity.
So this is a little different
from most of our games.
Most of our games we
have a finite board.
There's some rectangular thing.
Sometimes Life is
played on a torus.
So when you go off
the south edge,
you end up on the
north edge, and so on.
In that setting, Life is
going to be PSPACE complete.
So in general for
zero-player games,
if we have a polynomial number
of moves, then of course
we're going to be
in polynomial time.
If we have an unbounded
number of moves
but a polynomial space,
basically, then we're
going to get PSPACE.
OK.
No surprise.
So the finite versions of
Life will be like that.
But if we have infinite
space, normally we
can't think about
infinite space.
But with Life it's meaningful
to have an infinite board.
But initially only a finite
rectangle has any stuff in it.
So if you just encode all of the
positions of the living cells
and say, well everything
outside of that is dead,
then you can think
about infinite space.
And here we will get that
the problem is undecidable.
So there's no finite
algorithm to solve it.
So that's cool.
And I'm going to tell you a
little bit about both of these.
Spaceship is like
a glider, but it
goes in one dimension
instead of diagonally.
So usually horizontally.
There are many
spaceships out there.
This is one particularly
efficient one.
And one of the coolest
things is this thing
called Gosper glider gun,
invented by Bill Gosper,
I think while he was at MIT.
It's this construction up here.
And it creates gliders.
And so they just
go off to infinity.
And you just keep making more,
and more, and more of them.
So in some infinite sense, this
thing is periodic, I guess.
But at any finite time you have
maybe n of these coming out.
And you just keep
making more and more.
Gliders and glider
guns are the key things
you should know about
for hardness proofs.
First I'm just going to show you
a couple of pictures of fairly
recent hardness proofs.
This is an explicit construction
of a particular Turing machine.
I think it is a Turing machine
that given a number represented
in unary doubles that number.
So it's a fairly clean
machine, which is in here.
And there's two stacks.
So you can think of
a Turing machine,
normally you have a tape.
And you have your head
at some cell in the tape.
You can think of that as a
stack going to your left,
and a stack going to your right.
Each time you can pop off
an item from the stack
and push it onto the other side.
That would be the same
as moving to the left
or moving to the right.
So this is implementing
what's called
a pushdown automaton
with two stacks,
but basically a Turing
machine with one tape.
And you can do that.
And this is done
algorithmically.
So he also applied it to a
universal Turing machine,
if you're more a fan of that.
That's the Turing machine that
takes a Turing machine as input
and simulates it.
So that's the code in here.
It's much bigger.
Now this construction relies
on the tape being finite.
So it proves PSPACE completeness
for the polynomial space
version.
It will remain in this
rectangle, as big as it is.
And it will run the machine.
If it ran out of
tape, then the machine
might crash or not
do the thing that it
was supposed to do if
it was a Turing machine.
So that's fine for
PSPACE hardness,
because simulating a
Turing machine is hard.
I mentioned that last time.
But not good for undecidability.
Same guy a year later came
up with a Turing machine that
grows itself automatically.
So it's a little hard to see,
but this is the original thing.
And then as you run
it longer and longer,
this machine moves
along this dotted line.
So it's moved here.
This is like the dirt
that it leaves behind.
And simultaneously
it's been building
larger and larger versions
of its stacks, so by the time
it needs to use it,
it will be available.
Because space is
bounded by time.
So limit on the rate of growth.
Very complicated, obviously.
But extremely powerful.
This establishes that
some version of Life
like, will the thing ever
stop growing, is undecidable.
Cause if the machine halts,
you could make this thing
just stop.
It will non answer the question
of, given a life setup,
will everything
eventually disappear?
At least not easily.
So I'm going to talk about
that version and a somewhat
older proof, partly
because I like old proofs.
And it's a very epic proof.
So this one, I don't
understand the details of.
But they are online if you
want to study this thing.
There is another proof by
Berlekamp, Conway, and Guy
in their series of books
called Winning Ways, which
is a very cool set of books.
Interested in two-player
games in particular.
But they have this chapter
about life being undecidable.
At a high level
it's very simple.
It's just if you
have a glider, that's
going to represent a 1 bit.
If you don't have a glider
in a particular area,
that's going to
represent a zero bit.
And so you can think
of streams of bits
and doing stuff
with them over time.
And so that's cool.
Everything's going to be
oriented diagonally, of course.
Now one useful structure.
That's going to be our wire.
We can also build a terminator.
They call these eaters.
So this is a
particular construction
where-- and this
is frame-by-frame--
if the glider comes
in here, it basically
gets eaten by the eater,
and the eater remains.
The notation, by the
way, is that the dots
are going to be newly born
positions in the next step.
And the holes are going
to die in the next step.
So you can see the transition.
Stuff happens.
These are just things
you need to check.
And boom, it ends up
just the eater remains.
The eater is
otherwise still life.
So it will just hang out.
So you can send
gliders into an eater,
and they'll just disappear.
One thing to note is
that the exact offset
of this stream versus the
eater is very critical.
You do something a
little different,
eater might explode or
do something else weird.
So if you're going to
build these, be careful.
We'll talk a little bit
more about parity and things
in a moment.
OK.
So here's a fun thing you can
do with a glider gun up top,
and a stream of bits.
So if you have a stream
of bits coming in here.
And you have a glider gun
shooting one, one, one, one
down, then if you
set up your gliders
with the exact right
offsets-- so I've
got to shift that
gun to be precise--
and then when gliders
hit each other,
they annihilate each other.
Nothing is left with
this particular offset.
So what that means
is in some sense
you're negating the signal.
If a 1 comes in here,
it'll hit another 1.
And then 0 will come out here.
But in particular,
if there's a 0 here,
there will be nothing to stop
this guy from going through,
so you get a 1 out.
So this isn't really a
negation, because whenever
it's horizontal, it's
going to be one way.
And whenever it's negative,
it's going to be inverted.
But this is really a turn.
So if I turn this and
then turn it back,
which I think is the next
image, I can now turn a wire.
So this is progress, but
already a little challenging.
So we have this input wire
gets turned by the gun.
Turn back, turn back, turn back.
So sufficiently zoomed out,
you can do arbitrary turns.
You can use this to delay
signals, which is useful,
because timing is really
sensitive here with the wires
and when there's a
one bit or a zero bit.
Another thing you
can do with this
is get a parity offset shift.
Because there are actually
many different offsets
of the gliders that all lead to
evaporation and into nothing.
So you have to believe
this a little bit,
but there are enough
different offsets here
that by doing a bunch of
turns like in this picture,
with slightly different
offsets of each of these guns,
you can shift your signal to be
anywhere you want on the grid.
That's good, because
all the gadgets will
require very careful alignment.
So, that's a shift.
So now here's how we can do
AND and OR gates pretty easily.
So on the one hand, if
we have two streams A, B,
and we want to make
the end of them.
We're going to use
a single glider gun
to kind of merge them together.
So a 1 is going to get
through here if and only
if there was a 0 here.
And in that case, it
will prevent any A
from getting through.
So if B was false, there's a 0,
then there'll be a glider here.
And it will annihilate whatever
was an A, so the AND will be 0.
On the other hand, maybe
both of them are 0.
Then the glider will just
go up here to the eater
and disappear.
So that's also fine.
And if A is zero, then there
will be nothing over there,
obviously.
And if they're both one,
then A will get through,
because B will prevent the
gun here from getting there.
So A and B have to be
sort of offset in time,
because it takes a little
bit longer for the signal
to get here, but
you get the And.
And similarly for the OR, if
you want to send up a gun here,
and then it's essentially
getting negated on the right.
So for there to be
an output in the OR,
there must be nothing here.
And so for a glider
to be blocked,
either A blocks
it or B blocks it.
So then the output
is the OR of A and B.
And because everything
here is horizontal,
we're not negating anything.
That's actually annoying.
It would be better if
we had an AND and an OR.
Or an AND or an OR, cause
then it would be done.
So we still need negation.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: If you go
back into this line,
you are going to have
this A and B output
there as well, to
get the terminator.
In the right-hand diagram.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Right.
Sorry.
So there should also
be an eater here,
because this is
not fully occupied.
Good.
But because this
is fully occupied,
we don't need an eater there.
Cause this is fully occupied,
we don't need and eater here.
You could put them
in for good measure.
But, cool.
So before I show
you the next gadget,
I need another fun tool
called the kick back.
So this is of somewhat weirder
offset between two gliders.
So one's coming in this way,
the other is coming in this way.
And stuff happens.
And then this glider
goes backwards.
Returns along its original spot.
So this is really cool.
It means if you're
sending a glider,
if you can kind of
head it off at the pass
with the perpendicular
glider, you
can cause that glider to come
back the way it was going.
Which I think exactly
the same offset, even.
So this is useful
for a lot of things.
In particular, it lets
us build a crossover.
So the idea with a
crossover is that instead
of every-- a glider gun produces
gliders at a certain rate.
Call that rate one.
When it's so dense, if
you cross two streams,
you're guaranteed collisions
and something unintentional
will happen.
But if I could just
thin out the stream so
that every 10th
position is a glider,
and then we only look at the
bits, you know, modular 10,
then there will be no
problem to do crossings.
You just have to set up the
parity so that the gap happens
whenever the other guy happens.
And vice versa.
So they'll never
collide with each other.
Even if it's all ones.
So here's how you
thin out a stream.
We have a single
glider here, which
is just going to be kicked back
and forth, just hanging out.
And on the other hand, we
have these guns-- G1, G2, G3.
So this is going to
replace a single gun.
So this is the notation for
the kickback minute mechanism.
So mostly these guys are
just going to shoot off.
But they're set up so that
if this glider comes here,
he gets kicked back.
And also we lose
one glider here,
but they're going to
eat it all up anyway,
so it doesn't matter.
And same thing over here.
So this guy is mostly ones,
but every once in awhile
this glider will come
in and get kickback,
and consume one of the
gliders down this G2 stream.
So there will be a
couple holes here.
And then if you basically
negate that stream,
so you send another
glider down through here,
then only every once in
awhile will you have a glider.
And by controlling this width,
you can control the rate.
And I think in this
proof, you just
need all of them the same rate.
Sufficiently large
to allow crossovers.
OK.
Cool.
So that's thinning
and crossover.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are glider
gun constructions
that we know about, or
as least know about it
at the time [INAUDIBLE]
enough that you can't just
set the rate of fire from
the gun construction use.
AUDIENCE: There's a gun for
every period either greater
than or equal to 14.
PROFESSOR: Oh, cool.
According to--
AUDIENCE: Wikipedia.
PROFESSOR: Wikipedia.
Must be true.
I'll make a weak claim
to the extent to which I
know glider guns, these
are not like easily
variable constructions.
They're kind of magical,
and they just work.
There are probably many
different glider guns,
each with a different rate.
But I don't think there's
a general purpose glider
gun with an arbitrary rate.
Now there might
be one by now that
has a slow enough
rate that we're OK.
But I don't know.
So this certainly guarantees
that yeah, you could do it.
It's a little bit messy, but
maybe there's a simpler one.
Life is still actively studied
so there are many more guns
and there were in
the early '80s so I
think I won't go through
this construction in detail,
but using orders
and some kickbacks
and some crazy
ideas with guns, you
could build a split and a not.
Is that OK?
In particular, we're using
this idea of rate limiting,
so there's a lot of zeroes here.
And this is, whatever,
10 spots-- there's
only one every 10 spots.
And there's two cases, depending
on whether A is there or not.
And by ORing it
together with something,
and then having all
these chain reactions,
we end up with a copy of A
here, and a negated copy of A
hear with different offsets.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So for
NOT, isn't there
the super easy gadget
of A equal gun,
and then-- sorry-- the gun
gets through if A is not there.
PROFESSOR: That's what we
had for the turn gadget,
but it always turns the signal.
AUDIENCE: And that's bad?
PROFESSOR: That's
bad because it means
if you think of your gadgets
having inputs horizontally,
then you need to negate
and still be horizontal.
So this negates and
still is horizontal.
In their writeup, they actually
call the turn a NOT gadget.
But I think that's not NOT.
It depends on your perspective.
You definitely need a
direction-preserving NOT.
OK.
So that's cool.
And at this point, they say
just give this to the engineers
and they'll build a computer.
Once you have AND or NOT,
you can build binary logic,
so you can do
CIRCUIT-SAT style things.
And you could make
re-entrant circuits.
And so you can compute
on stuff and build
a Turing machine
with a finite size,
or any machine of finite
size, bounded size.
So that's enough to
prove PSPACE hardness.
But if you want to
prove undecidability,
you need some way to
grow up to infinity.
And their idea is to have a
small number of registers.
Two are enough.
This is called a Minsky machine,
is the two-counter version.
And Minsky proved that you
can simulate a Turing machine
with two counters.
What's a counter?
It stores a
non-negative integer.
And you have three operations--
increment, decrement, and check
whether it's 0.
So it's a little crazy.
But that's enough to
simulate an entire Turing
machine with infinite tape.
So the rough idea is to
store a bit onto the tape.
You double it and
possibly add one.
And if you want to remove
something from the stack,
then you divide by 2.
So with four
registers, you can use
this one to represent
one stack, and this one
to represent the other stack.
Dot, dot, dot.
It's not too hard.
So how are we going to represent
an arbitrary non-negative
integer?
We're going to have
a little 2 by 2
box-- this is drawn diagonally--
somewhere along this ray.
And then we're going to be
able to increment or decrement
the box by sending
a wave of gliders
using these constructions.
Sorry, next slide we'll have the
constructions for incrementing.
Here actually is a
glider that's going
to test whether this
guy's currently zero.
And he happens to be.
And so here's how you test.
I mean, you just send a
glider through the box.
And there may be a cleaner test.
This one is a destructive test.
It destroys the box.
But in particular, it
destroys the glider.
So then you can have a gate
on this side that says, well,
if I didn't get a glider, then
I know that I'm actually 0,
and I can feed that back
to my logic circuit.
If I do get a glider, then
I know this was empty.
So that's pretty easy.
The only catch is then
you've destroyed the box.
You have to create a new box.
And you can do that by sending
two gliders with a slightly
different offset.
This looks like this same as
all the others, but in this one
you end up with
a box at the end.
So if you send like
another one here
and another one timed
just right here,
you'll recreate the
box after you've
discovered that it was there.
So that's cool.
And then this is a swarm.
I think it's actually drawn
somewhat accurately to push
this block forward by 1.
I think it's this stream.
So there are two
constructions here.
One is a wave of gliders that
pulls it a block back by 3,
another one pushes
it forward by 1.
Together you could use this to
increment or decrement by 1.
So I mean, lots of
details to check here.
This one is a
little bit cleaner.
We have one glider here,
a second glide here.
And it ends up moving.
It goes in this
order and then back.
And we end up moving the box
up to here, back three spaces.
I assume these are found
by trial and error.
And then to push a block
forward 1, this is pretty crazy.
Their second wave
of five gliders.
Where's the first wave?
AUDIENCE: Turning the
block into a honey farm.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Turning the block
into a honey farm,
which is this particular
still life pattern.
Anyway.
Dot, dot, dot.
You check the results.
It works.
It's actually a lot
of fun to implement
these in a life simulator
and check that it works.
But for now I'm showing
you the ancient diagrams,
hand-drawn diagrams.
OK.
So there's like a
catch with this.
In order to generate these
gliders in this very specific
pattern, currently the only
way we have of making gliders
is with the glider gun.
Glider guns are large objects.
And you can't put them
right next to each other.
And even worse, if
you have a glider gun,
it's spitting out gliders
in the middle of it.
You can't put a glider gun
shifted over a little bit
even if you slide it
this way or that way.
If you want to
produce two streams
very close to each
other, one of them
will go through the other glider
gun and destroy the glider gun.
So you can't actually
build this kind of pattern
with glider guns ultimately.
But there's this
trick using kickbacks
to get a glider to go out
far away from any guns.
And this is to-- so
here's your original gun.
And this one has
some holes in it.
So you can get a
glider through here.
And then get this glider to
bounce back and forth until you
have the right timing.
Then this glider will escape
through this little gap.
And then the result is, you
send the glider basically offset
to the right from this gun.
So using that, you can
have a bunch of glider guns
sort of around
where you need it.
Get all the gliders to come up.
And now you're very narrow.
You could have two gliders
right next to each other
without any trouble.
So you do a bunch of
these constructions
at various heights.
So this is the picture of
two glider guns, one shooting
a glider through the other.
That's bad.
So instead, we'll put
these away from it,
and send the gliders offset
to be like that, using
two of these constructions.
OK.
So now we can increment and
decrement, and test for 0.
With this similar trick
we can do some fun stuff
in sending gliders
forward and backward.
So this is cool.
Remember I said that
you could send a glider
and cause it to come
back using the kickback.
So normally if you
want to send the glider
and have it come back,
you need another glider
to be shot this way.
So that's OK in some cases.
But here's a cool construction
where all the gliders are
way down here, and still I
can make the glider go up
and then come back
at some desired time.
And it's the same kind of idea.
You use this construction
to make this glider go back
and forth, spend lots of time.
And then eventually hit this guy
at just the right orientation
to send it back.
And if you have
some more stuff, you
could actually get it to go
back and forth many times
and come over
farther to the right.
Why do I care about this?
For self-destruction.
So the idea is if the Turing
machine says yes, if it stops,
then you want the entire
thing to collapse to nothing.
And so when you get
to this magical state,
you're going to send out
a whole bunch of gliders,
and then turn them around using
the mechanism I just showed--
the boomerang--
and get them to hit
every gadget in the construction
at exactly the right offset
to make them disappear.
This is how you kill an eater
from going from slightly
wrong orientation.
This is how you destroy a gun.
It ends up with nothing.
Oh.
Sorry.
This is a gun.
This is a how you
destroy a square.
We already saw that.
So all of that infrastructure
being able to precisely place
gliders exactly where you need
them, lots of details to check.
But you should be able
to get them all come out
and come back.
And you always hit them in
the backside of the guns.
I think first you kill
all the guns so they
stop generating gliders.
You let the gliders
get eaten by eaters.
And then you go out and destroy
all the eaters and squares
and so on.
So, pretty epic.
But in the end we
get undecidability
of life in an infinite board.
So zero-player is
more interesting
than you might expect.
This is certainly
one of the more epic
proofs in that direction.
Next thing I want
to tell you about
is zero-player constraint logic.
This is called deterministic
constraint logic, as opposed
to nondeterministic
constraint logic, which
we talked about last time.
So let me define it for you.
So in deterministic
constraint logic
we have a little bit more state.
Before it's just in
the state of a machine
is just the orientations
of all the edges.
Now we're also
going to have-- it's
a little hard to see
on this projector--
but there's some highlighted
edges which are active.
So I'll describe what
they are in a moment.
So even if you can't see
them, they are there.
Active literally means that
you just flipped the edge
in the previous step.
So deterministic
constraint logic,
we're going to be flipping
multiple edges at once
in one round.
And in the next round, those
edges are all called active.
And the rest are inactive.
Now that's for edges.
We're going to define a
vertex to be active basically
if that reversal did
something useful.
So if its active incoming
edges have total weight greater
or equal to 2.
So if the just flipped edges
satisfy that vertex possibly
in a new way, then we
call the vertex active.
It's been activated by
what just got flipped.
And then here's what we're
going to do in each round.
We are going to reverse
inactive edges pointing
to active vertices.
And we're going to reverse
active edges pointing
to inactive vertices.
And then these reversed edges
are the new active edges.
OK.
So let's look at an example.
So here's a little gadget.
We're actually going
to use this gadget
in proving PSPACE
completeness of this model.
And initially just
this edge is active.
And if that's all that happens--
now there's some inputs
and outputs here-- if
that's all that happens,
this edge is active.
It alone does not
satisfy this vertex.
So this vertex is inactive.
And in the inactive case,
if the vertex is inactive,
we're supposed to
reverse the active edge.
This is basically bouncing back.
If you try to
satisfy a vertex, you
didn't satisfy it, you
just undo what you did.
You're going to
reverse the edge.
So what's going to
happen here is this guy
will just flip back and forth.
First he's gonna go this way.
Says, oh, I didn't
satisfy this one.
So I'll reverse this edge.
Now it points into here.
Still doesn't
satisfy that vertex.
It's inactive.
So this guy will just
flip back and forth
forever until here we're
drawing the picture where
A reverses, so because
of some gadget below it.
Suppose A reverses at the same
time this one is reversing.
So now this edge is active.
And this edge is active.
Still this guy didn't
satisfy what he wants.
So he's going to reverse
again in the next step.
But this guy did satisfy the
vertex because he has weight 2.
So now it alone
satisfies this vertex.
So now both of these
are going to reverse.
This is the forward case.
We have a active edge
satisfying-- so now
this vertex is active.
We're going to reverse
these inactive edges which
point to the active vertex.
So we end up flipping those.
Now they're pointing
out of the vertex.
This one remains pointing in.
It's no longer active, because
we didn't just flip it.
So we propagate from this
being active to these two being
active.
This is a splitter.
We have the signal and we
split it into two parts.
So it's acting like the
splitter that we know and love
from last lecture.
OK.
Meanwhile, this guy
just reversed again.
But now these two are
simultaneously here.
So together, those two active
edges satisfy the vertex.
So this vertex is active, which
will flip that edge up there.
Yes.
I should say this vertex
is a little bit weird.
You could think of there being
a red to blue conversion here.
This guy only has a
desired weight of 1.
This is basically a
red edge, but it's
subdivided to fix the timing.
So we'll see how to get
rid of that subdivision.
But you can think of
this as a red to blue.
And there's two blue edges here.
But this one edge will
actually satisfy this vertex.
And so then this guy
flips in the next stage.
And then it's just
going to hang out here,
flipping back and
forth along this path.
And meanwhile, this will
go off and do something
until it comes back
and reverses the edge.
And I should say at this
point-- because there
are a lot of timing
issues here, we're
going to set up all the
gadgets so that they only
get an input edge reversed
at times divisible by 4.
So this one happened at time 0.
And then this one we know will
happen at a certain parity
relative to 4.
And so we know when this
guy has gotten flipped,
this one will also
have just been flipped.
And then stuff happens.
And then this edge ends
up getting reversed.
And then more stuff happens.
Then this edge gets
reversed again.
And then the A gets
So this gadget has
sort of three cycles.
When you reverse A, first B will
reverse, then C will reverse,
then B will reverse,
then A will reverse.
It's a little bit overkill.
But we're going to use
this to check two options.
We're just going to
check one of them
twice because that's
what we can build easily.
OK.
So now we want to prove PSPACE
completeness of this model.
The decision question is again,
does a particular edge ever
get reversed?
And so we're going to reduce in
the usual way from quantified
CNF-SAT.
We have our blocks which
represent quantifiers.
They're going to produce
variable settings.
We're going to have
some CNF logic.
And then in the end, this is
actually not quite accurate.
We're going to get some
satisfied signal which
is piped into these guys.
So the first thing
that has to change
are the quantifier gadgets.
In particular, the
existential quantifier
needs to change because before
we let the player decide
whether to choose x or x bar.
So in this case, we're going
to use the gadget you just saw,
the little wheel, which
will try x being false.
Then it will try x being true,
then it will try x being false.
And all we need is that
one of them is true.
So if at any point this
formula is satisfied,
we'll just output that
formula satisfied.
We have four edges here
because everything needs
to work modular 4 in timing.
So there's a little bit
more going on here, which
I will get into in a moment.
On the other hand, universal
quantifier is similar.
I think I will leave it at that.
There's this generator
to try all the options.
This is going to act in
some sense like the one
bit of memory, the latch,
that we had before.
So it's similar.
But I think the details
are not worth getting into.
If you look at the appendix of
Games, Puzzles, Computation,
you'll see an explicit
execution of this thing.
I mean, it's like life.
You just run it through
and see if it works.
And it does.
So what's going on
up here is that when
we set x bar to be false,
we're going to flip this edge.
And we're basically telling
the circuit, hey, x is false.
And then at some
point it's going
to acknowledge and say, OK.
I understand that x is false.
But that's going to be
on a different channel.
So let me illustrate the issue.
So this is how we
used to do CNF logic.
We did ANDs of ORs using OR
vertices and AND vertices.
And that was cool if we had
a signal for what was true
and what was false,
we could throw away
signals we didn't need.
Then this would propagate
and produce a true answer.
Nondeterministically it would.
But deterministically there's
a lot of timing issues here.
Everything has to arrive
at the inputs at exactly
the same time.
And AND will only work if
this edge and this edge
simultaneously reverse.
So OK.
Maybe you could subdivide enough
edges to fix the timing issue.
But it's worse than that.
If you're doing an
AND of two things,
and you discover that
the answer is false,
then all bets are off.
So normally that would be
OK, because we can always
undo what we did.
But we need to guarantee that
the deterministic constraint
machine will exactly undo
what it was supposed to do.
So it's an issue that if
one of these comes in true
and the other's false,
this one will bounce back
and then chaos will happen.
We'll end up getting
edges just randomly
reversing it at annoying times.
So that seems messy.
And so instead we build
this much safer version
called AND prime, OR prime,
and split prime, I guess.
There should be a prime
there where each input
is represented by two things.
First the signal, and
then the acknowledgement.
And so there's some
details to check here.
The OR is particularly messy.
But these are just deterministic
constraint logic machines.
You see this gadget yet
again to try various things.
But in this case, if
input 1 comes at sometime
before input 2, then it will
essentially-- so this comes up.
The signal gets split out here.
And so we send off
the acknowledgement.
And then this edge
will, I think,
just be flipping back and forth.
So it's basically holding
the input for awhile.
And later, the second
input could come in.
And it will trigger
this to happen, and also
trigger the output, and also
trigger the acknowledgement,
cause it does all the things.
So that is roughly
how that works.
So I think the details are not
worth spending more time on.
This is the final thing after
you have all the CNF logic come
out, then this is how
you end up sending
it to satisfy out to the
quantifiers, which are here.
So it's a bit messy.
But the main point
is that this works.
And so hopefully we can use
deterministic constraint logic
to prove lots of interesting
zero-player games are hard.
We don't know very many
interesting zero-player games.
So please help in finding them.
There's one detail I'd
like to get rid of though.
These degree 2 vertices, it
would be nicer to avoid those.
So this is a bunch of reductions
to get rid of degree 2 vertices
and keep things mod 4.
So we're going to
take every edge
and subdivide it into
a path of length 4,
because then if we have two
red edges in the original graph
together, instead of replacing
it by two red paths of length
4, we're going to
replace it by two paths
here, with the first
and last edge being red,
but everything else being blue.
The motivation
for that is now we
just have blue, blue
edges and red, blue edges.
No red, reds.
To get a blue, blue, we just
add on a thing like this
that's forced to be out.
And this will be satisfied if
and only if one of these is in.
So we've done that
kind of trick before.
And red, blue edges, we've
explicitly done before.
So we know how to
deal with those.
And so we do all the
subdivision in order
to get rid of the red, reds.
Also where these guys have
a smaller weight constraint,
just one of them has to be in.
So now we have no
degree 2 vertices.
The other thing is, we
have a non-planar graph.
It would be nice to get
rid of the crossings.
AUDIENCE: Don't you still
have a timing issue?
PROFESSOR: This should preserve
the fact that everything
happens at time 0 mod 4.
So we'll slow everything
down by a factor of 4.
But it shouldn't
be a timing issue.
And because these
things are rigid,
they don't have any timing.
OK.
So next we get rid of crossings.
This actually is a
little easier for once.
This was how we implemented
a red, red, red, red vertex
in the crossover gadget for NCL.
But here it's actually
enough as a crossover,
because we have the luxury
of timing in some sense.
There are a lot of
things that could've
happened undeterministically
that just
can't happen deterministically.
So does it work?
Here I pasted in the figure.
You run it through and you check
that it works in both cases.
If they don't activate at
the same time, then it works.
Activated at the same time, I
don't know what would happen.
But we can offset all the timing
so there are no collisions.
And boom, we get crossovers.
So the conclusion is
deterministic constraint logic
is PSPACE complete for
a planar and OR graphs.
I think I actually
want to also say split.
So normally we think of AND
and OR as the same thing.
But it is helpful to
distinguish them based
on their initial orientations.
An AND would
probably be this way.
Because you want
to activate this,
and you can only do that if both
of these have been activated.
And so this is the output.
For a split, this is the input.
So it's initially not active.
And then it wold look
something like that.
So if you want to
distinguish between these two
vertex-- sorry.
This should be the other way.
If you want to distinguish what
the initial orientations are,
then you also need
to list split here.
So up to you whether you
feel like doing that.
OK.
That's all I want to say
about zero-player games.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: What should
happen in the end?
Everything is--
PROFESSOR: In the end, if you
satisfy the whole formula then
you will get here,
this edge will reverse.
And so the decision question
is, does this edge reverse?
Either it will or it won't.
In both cases, I think
the behavior's periodic.
Because it's a funny thing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So there were
two decision problems
for nondeterministic
constraint logic.
One of them was can you
reach this configuration.
Another one was can
you fit this edge?
Do you know anything about--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
OK.
If you want to
solve configuration
to configuration for DCL,
I think you can basically
add some red edges here.
So if this thing
activates-- well,
you need to do a little bit
more of a construction here.
But I want to
basically get an edge
to start flipping over here.
Whereas before it
was not flipping.
I think you can get
an edge flipping,
and then everything inverts.
And then you will be in
the original configuration,
except this guy
will be flipping.
If you set your parity
right, then he'll
be flipped in a state
where everything else is
in its original state.
So, pretty sure.
I forget whether
that's in the book.
But I think configuration to
configuration, also PSPACE
complete for DCL.
Good.
So let's move on to
multiplayer games.
First I'd like to reduce
to the two-player case.
So there's a big difference
between one and two players.
But there's not so
big a difference
between two and three and
four and five and six players.
At least the usual
decision problem
is, does the first player
have a winning strategy.
Can the first player
win, basically.
Sometimes this is
called a forced win.
If a player forces a win.
If you think of it this way,
and all the other players
are free agents,
then the worst case
is when they all collude
to try to make you not win.
So that would be the
opposite of a forced win.
If it's not possible
for you to force a win,
that means the players can
somehow work together in order
to prevent you from winning.
So in that sense, they are
all essentially one player.
You can thinking of
them as one hive mind.
Now in the mechanics
of the game, of course
there are differences between
two players and three players,
because they have more
power in some sense.
They can do three things for
every time you do one thing.
But at some level that is
just a two-player game again,
where you are
relatively impoverished
compared to your opponent.
So the asymmetric,
but still two-player
game from a
complexity standpoint.
So we just need to think
about two-player games
and their complexity.
Later we'll add some variations
that make this not true.
But in a perfect information
deterministic game,
this is true, this
reduction is true.
So for a two
players, we're going
to have-- at least
for the duration
of this lecture--
the two players will
be called white and black.
In Winning Ways for example,
they're called red and blue.
But this is problematic
because we have
red and blue edges already.
And I want red, white edges and
blue, black edges and so on.
So the players will be white and
black as in chess, checkers--
not checkers.
Go, whatever.
But color renaming.
OK.
And I'm going to
focus today on games
that have a polynomial number
of moves in any execution, which
places the problem into PSPACE.
So again, we're going to
aim for PSPACE completeness.
It's PSPACE because you
can think of this question
as being equivalent to, do I
have a move such that no matter
how the opponent
responds to that move--
so every move for
the opponent, which
I will call response--
I have another move
such that no matter what
the opponent does dot,
dot, dot through the
polynomial number of moves.
If there's only a
polynomial in many moves,
then there's only a polynomial
number of quantifiers here.
And then in the
formula I'm going
to write whatever
the rules of the game
are, and then AND it
together with I win.
I think you believe
almost all games you
can write as some Boolean
formula to do that.
Some polynomial-sized Boolean
formula saying at each
step you satisfy what you need.
And so this is a QSAT problem.
And therefore, any
two-player game
where you can write moves and
responses succinctly and have
a polynomial number
of moves is in PSPACE,
because you can
reduce it to QSAT.
OK.
So that's why
PSPACE is the class
we care about for
polynomially bounded games.
So now we want to
prove hardness.
And first I want to give
you some hard problems
in this setting starting
with SAT-style games.
This is from another paper
by Shaefer, same guy who
did Shaefer Dichotomy Theorem.
He also did some
nice stuff on games.
So first game is just your
favorite flavor of QSAT.
You can think of it as a game.
Because QSAT is exactly of this
form, you can think of the game
as-- in your first move you're
going to choose this variable.
In your second
move, your opponent
is going to choose
this variable.
In the third move you
choose this variable.
And so on.
Because play alternates,
you are following
exactly an alternating
quantifier kind of thing.
And the goal of player one
is to satisfy this formula.
The goal player two is to have
it not satisfied in the end.
And so player one
will win if and only
if this formula is true.
So in the game, you think of
it as there are a sequence
of variables-- x1, x2, x3.
Play alternates between
assigning xi and xi plus 1.
Player one's always
assigning the odd variables.
Player two is always
assigning the even variables.
And then if the
formula is satisfied,
then player one wins.
OK.
So this is what you
might call the game
version of a satisfiable formula
is that player one wins if
and only if the formula
is satisfied in the end.
But there's some
other goal conditions
you might consider
that Schaefer defines.
One is called Seek,
which is the first player
to satisfy the formula wins.
And so in general, if you're
choosing some variables,
you have a set of
variables, some of them
have been assigned 0 or 1.
Some of them haven't
been assigned yet.
So when I say
satisfy here, I mean
that unassigned things are 0.
So if you think of everything as
initially 0, whoever satisfies
the formula first wins.
Then the opposite
version is Void.
So the first person to
satisfy the formula loses.
So the formula starts false.
And the first person to set
it to true loses the game.
Other person wins.
OK.
So those are some rule
variations of the goal state.
Now let me tell you
about the moves.
So other than QSAT, we're going
to have two types of moves.
One is impartial moves.
Impartial means that both
players have the same moves.
So an impartial move is
going to be whoever's playing
sets an unassigned variable.
So on all of these
games, you can only
assign a variable once.
If you can assign
it multiple times,
then you're no longer
polynomially bounded,
and you get x time completeness.
But for the polynomially
bounded games,
we're going to define
each variable can only
be assigned once.
And in a partial
game, any player
can assign any variable
that's not yet assigned.
OK.
So whereas in QSAT, you
had a fixed ordering.
First x1, then x2, then x3.
An impartial game
version of SAT, players
take turns setting
variables, any one they want.
It's not yet assigned.
And in the end, if the formula
is satisfied, player one wins.
That would be impartial game.
But I could also do impartial
seek, impartial void.
And then by the way,
I made up these names.
So they don't match
what Shaefer calls them.
But these are more modern.
These terms are in
Winning Ways, for example.
Seek and Avoid he used.
But the other ones I made up.
OK.
Partisan version is that
there are white variables
and there are black variables.
And the white player can
only set white variables,
black player can only
set black variables.
There's 50% of each.
And so they balance if you
play all the way to the end,
like in the game
version, then it's
OK to have the white player play
any unsatisfied white variable
and set it to true or false.
I think that defines all
the games that I want.
Now let me tell you which
combinations are PSPACE
complete.
A bunch of them.
So impartial.
In addition to this
characterization,
there's also all the different
versions of SAT that we know.
So we have impartial
game positive 11-SAT.
So this is a version of CNF.
Instead of 3-SAT, I have 11-SAT.
There are no negative literals.
And it's impartial.
So anyone could
set any variable.
And it's the game
version, so player one
wants to set it true.
Player two wants the
formula to be false.
That's PSPACE complete.
Also, if we do 11-DNF-SAT, so
a DNF formula with positive.
This is also as hard.
I mean, that essentially
corresponds to flipping
all the quantifiers.
So that doesn't make
a big difference.
So this is cool because
positive SAT is usually
pretty easy with all
existential quantifiers.
With alternating
quantifiers, not so easy.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is impartial game
positive 10-SAT [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: We don't
know the exact cutoff.
There is a paper, I think,
proving six is enough.
But the positive disappears.
So I think that's an open
problem, how low you could go.
It's hard to do the
usual kind of reductions
from many occurrences
to fewer, because games
are very sensitive about who's
playing win, timing, and so on.
So next one is
partisan game CNF-SAT.
Here we don't have positive.
And we don't have the bound 11.
But we changed
impartial to partisan.
That still is hard.
And next we have a
whole bunch of games
that work both for impartial
and partisan moves.
OK.
So we have avoid
positive 2-DNF-SAT.
We have seek positive 3-DNF-SAT.
We have avoid positive CNF-SAT.
And we have seek
positive CNF-SAT.
So the main point is,
most combinations are
hard for some version of SAT.
And these are the tightest
ones that Shaefer could show.
Doesn't necessarily
mean that they're tight.
And there's no
dichotomy theorem here,
so we don't know exactly
which problems are hard.
But this is a ton of
games to start from.
And in particular, we're going
to use at least one of them.
OK.
Let's maybe go over here.
A couple more problems
which are in Shaefer paper.
One's called Kayles,
one is called Geography.
Kayles is essentially
the two-player version
of independent set.
So there are a
couple of versions.
There is node Kayles and
bipartite node Kayles.
These are the traditional names.
You could also think of
this is impartial Kayles
and this as partisan Kayles.
So here the moves
are all the same.
The moves are here.
Pick any vertex, add
to an independent set.
That's a move.
So players take turns adding.
At all times, you
must add a vertex
that keeps it independent set.
So you're effectively
removing all
of its neighbors and itself.
Last player to move wins.
You can't move, you lose.
Bipartite node Kayles, you
have a bipartite graph.
And one side you call white,
one side you call black.
A white player can only
choose from the white side.
A black player can only
choose from the black side.
So these are both
PSPACE complete as well,
via reductions from
these problems.
But I don't have those
reductions with me.
OK.
So that's independent set.
Geography is essentially
a two-player version
of Longest Path.
It's inspired by this
real-life game where
one person names
a city or country
or pick your favorite
class of objects.
And then the other
player must name
a word whose first letter
equals the last letter
of the previous word.
So you're forming
chains of words.
And you can think of that
as just having a graph where
vertices are the
words, the edges
are valid moves between words.
Do they have some
common property.
So in general, you're
given a directed graph
and you're given a start node.
And you have a token
at that start node.
A move in the game
is to follow an edge,
to move the token along an edge.
But then there's some
non-repetition condition.
So we have node geography
where you're not
allowed to repeat any notes.
That would be the
usual longest path.
And again, the last
player to move wins.
If you can't make a move,
you lose the game, just
like the real game.
And on the other hand,
we have edge geography,
which is more like
an [INAUDIBLE] path.
The longest edge
destroying path.
So edge geography you're
not allowed to repeat edges.
And for each one, you could
think of a directed graph,
you have to follow directed
edges or an undirected graph.
And here undirected,
no geography is NP.
Directed, no geography
if PSPACE complete.
And for edge geography,
surprisingly, both
are PSPACE complete.
So this is a useful problem.
I've seen a ton of PSPACE
completeness proofs
based on geography.
It's kind of conceptually clean.
And I will show you one now.
Everyone play Othello, Reversi.
In general, you
have these pieces
which are black on one
side, white on the other.
The black side is
the one that you play
if you're the black player.
But then you can, for example,
if you place a new black stone
here, given this
configuration, because there's
a black string of whites
and then a black here,
you end up flipping
that one over.
Because this is black and
then a bunch of whites,
or black and then a space,
nothing else happens.
In this picture though, if
you place this black thing,
this is black, a bunch of
whites, then black, black,
bunch of whites, black,
black, bunch of whites, black.
So all of those flip over.
And your goal is to
maximize your color.
You want more more stones of
your color than the opponent's.
OK.
Cool game.
Bounded number of moves,
polynomial number of moves,
because every time
you add a new stone,
you've occupied one of
the squares on the board.
And you'll never get that back.
So n by n board would be
exactly n squared minus 4 moves,
because four is the
original number.
So this is PSPACE
complete, given
a particular
configuration to decide
whether black has a
winning strategy, say,
is PSPACE complete.
And most of the
construction is in here.
This box is actually
this picture.
And that's going to
simulate geography.
But let me tell you
about this other part.
So right now white has
a huge amount of area.
This is actually really big.
So I guess this is very thin,
so there's not much action here.
Here you've got a huge
amount of white area.
So white will win unless
black can take this part.
And what happens is
there's a gap here.
And if black can play
any of these spots,
now black won't be
able to play here
if there's some corresponding
black thing over here.
So that's what these long
horizontal channels will be.
So if black can play over
here, because there's
a black stone and long
white channels here,
then this will flip to black.
And then in this
picture is this.
So if one of these stones
up here is now black,
that means you can
play at position alpha.
And if I play at position
alpha, black plays there.
Then I get black
all the way here.
White can't really
respond much to that.
And then in the next
black move, black
can go here and flip that one.
And then black can go
here in the corner.
Corners are very
important in Othello.
So once you take this corner
and flip all these things to be
black, then I can play here,
here, here, here, here, here,
here and take all of these.
And because this
is the edge, white
won't be able to
take anything back.
So that's the threat.
Each of these lines is
going to be a threat
that if any of these
become black over here,
white has to turn
them back to white.
Otherwise, in the very next
move, black will win the game.
OK.
A lot of two-player game proofs
have this constant notion
of threat.
One player's basically
just slogging
through trying to put out fires.
And the other
player is constantly
causing fires in order
to force the other player
to do what they want.
So it almost reduces
to a one-player game.
But there's still
some choices involved.
Well, these are not
terribly exciting.
But let me show you
the typical setup.
This is just a turn gadget, or
it could be a degree 2 vertex.
I should mention we're
reducing from directed
no geography, where this
is directed no geography.
Also max degree 3.
So that means you might
have a degree 2 vertex,
or you might have
a degree 3 vertex.
There are two types
of degree 3 directed
vertices merging and branching.
So we need gadgets
for each of these.
Also, bipartite.
Bipartite is useful
because in geography you're
always moving along an edge,
which means you'll always
be jumping from the left
side of the bipartition
to the right side.
So you can color the
edges black and white.
And black player will only
play in the black side,
and white player will only
play in the white side.
So this is good.
You can predict who's going
to be playing in each gadget.
So in a degree 2 gadget, it
works something like this.
If white has played
here, that will
be because of the other gadget.
This is the trigger.
Then now this is black, a
bunch of whites, and now black
can play here,
reversing all of these.
This is a threat line.
And there's now a
black square, which
means white must
immediately play here
in order to reverse all of
those stones back to white.
But now this is a white stone,
which lets this thing trigger.
So now black can play at the
end of this thing, et cetera.
So this just propagates
a signal, does a turn.
It's a degree 2 vertex.
Whatever.
All those things.
And this is slightly
different version
for a different orientation,
because these things
have to go to the left.
This looks a little different.
OK.
More interesting are
the degree 3 vertices.
This is the type where I have
two incoming edges and one
outgoing.
Key thing here is we need to
check that we do not visit
this vertex more than once.
We came in here and
then came in again.
We want something bad to happen.
Now what should
happen bad depends on
whether it was the white player
moving or the black player
moving. if it was the
white player moving
and they double visit, it
means white should lose.
If it was the black player
moving, and they double visit,
it means black should lose.
Because of the bipartiteness,
we know which gadget to use.
They're almost the same gadget.
Just these two dots
have been added.
So something like, if this
activates, and it's symmetric,
but let's say this one
activates by white playing here,
then black can play
here, flip all those,
which has this threat
line, which means white
must play here.
Flip them all back to white.
But now this B1
position is white,
which enables black to play
here, flip all those to black.
This is the threat line,
therefore white must play here.
Can't play there.
And turn all these
back to white.
Now this is white.
And now this
activates down there.
So that's just
following the vertex.
No big deal.
But if you came
along a second time
and activated this as white--
now this is already white.
So when you play black,
you get a black here.
And white can't do anything.
There's no white stone up there.
Yeah.
Well it's entirely black.
If there was a white
on either side,
white could flip it
and get them back.
But you can't.
And so you actually have
two threat lines activated.
And then black wins.
So this is the version
where black wins.
If instead, we have
a white thing here,
everything else is the same.
So this was white,
this was white.
Black now plays here.
Now white can go
here and completely
make this thing
white, and then black
doesn't have any moves anymore.
And that's the way that
white's going to win
is to prevent black
from playing anymore.
Then the area that was white
is white, so we're done.
There are lots of
details here to check,
but that's how it works.
There's one more
gadget basically
that says this is for
one incoming edge and two
outgoing edges.
So here you want the
players to have a choice,
either I go this way,
or I go this way.
And if it's a white vertex, you
want white to make that choice.
If it's a black vertex, you
want black to make that choice.
But black is still kind
of doing all the action.
So it can be done.
When this activates,
then black plays here,
flipping all these things.
Then white plays here,
immediately flipping it back.
That's the trouble, is
always black is in control.
Now black plays here,
flipping that one guy.
And white has two choices.
It can either play here and
flip just this one, or play here
and flip those guys.
And either put a
white here or here,
and that will end up
activating for black
either this path, or this path.
So white made the choice.
And in this version,
black makes the choice.
That's a little easier.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are these
gadgets constructable?
PROFESSOR: In an 8 by 8?
AUDIENCE: No.
Like from a starting
configuration.
Can you get to a configuration
of these gadgets?
PROFESSOR: Oh, I see.
I think so.
I didn't read that
as [INAUDIBLE],
but it wouldn't surprise
me if it's in the paper.
It's traditional in constructing
these generalized games
to actually show that you
can reach this position
from the initial state.
Although the problem makes
sense even if you can't.
It's more interesting to say,
well we played like crazy.
And then we ended
up with this thing.
Can you finish it off for me?
That's basically the
problem we'd like to solve.
Can white win?
It's like the
commentator problem.
People are playing.
And now I want to know who's
going to win at this point.
But I don't know for
sure for this reduction.
Usually they can.
OK.
So that's a sketch of
Othello PSPACE hardness
reduction from geography.
So the last thing I want to talk
about, back to this picture,
is the two-player setup
for constraint logic.
So polynomially
bounded, two-player game
should be PSPACE complete.
First I'm going to
talk briefly about what
does bounded mean in general
for constraint logic.
So in particular, for
one player which we know,
the bounded NCL means each
edge can flip only once.
That's our definition.
And that game is clearly
in NP, cause one you flip
all the edges, you're done.
And in the same way,
we prove that just
finding and satisfying
orientation of a constraint
graph is NP
complete, we can show
just I changed the very top
gadget, that bounded NCL,
you just want to flip this
one edge is NP complete.
Because you basically
have to make
a choice for each
of these vertices,
which way to set them.
And then you can propagate up.
We don't have to flip any edges
for this very simple proof.
So NP completeness
for a bounded NCL.
We do for this proof
need a choice gadget.
So all three red edges.
It doesn't work
to just blow it up
like we could before
in the bounded case.
OK.
And there's a crossover gadget
in this setting as well.
It's actually pretty
simple because a bounded
you can't revisit.
OK.
So now bounded two-player
constraint logic is called 2CL.
This is PSPACE complete by
pretty much the same proof
structure.
So what's the game?
I have white edges
and black edges.
Each edge is white or black,
and it's also red or blue.
Exclusive ORs.
So they're drawn as--
these are all white edges.
This is an example
of a black edge.
So the fill is white or black,
the outline is red or blue,
as before.
White players can
only flip white edges,
black players can
only flip black edges.
And otherwise it's
the same constraints.
I mean, the inflow
constraint doesn't care
whether you're black or white.
It's politically correct
vertices, I guess.
So we just need one
new type of vertex.
Everything else is going to
be done by the white player.
There's one new type
or vertex, which
is an incoming black edge
and an incoming white edge.
Call this a variable.
The idea is that wherever gets
there first, white or black
can flip it, preventing
the other player
from flipping their edge.
So that's what we're going
to use for variable settings.
And I'm reducing from--
remember the terminology here--
impartial game positive CNF-SAT.
The very first one here.
Impartial game positive CNF-SAT.
So player one's goal--
white is the player one.
Player one's goal is
to satisfy the formula
and flip their edge.
And it's the impartial
version, meaning anyone
can set any variable.
So if black plays
this edge, that's
going to correspond
to setting x2 false.
If white plays the
edge, it's going
to correspond to x being true.
Because this is a
positive formula,
every time white
choose a variable,
they're gonna want
to set it to true.
And every time black
sets a variable,
they're going to
set it to false,
because they want to prevent
satisfaction of the formula.
So that's why it's OK to
just represent it this way.
And then the rest
just propagates.
So if there are n
variables, there's
going to be n over 2 rounds
where all the variables get
set.
And then black can't
do anything else.
Just sitting there.
This one is not going
to be flippable because
of this gadget.
So white's just going
to fill in the formula.
And if it happens
to be come out true,
and white can flip their
edge, then they win the game.
And that will correspond
to the formula being true.
And otherwise, not.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So is pass
in that you can do?
Or they're just like--
PROFESSOR: In this
game you can pass.
I think you could
probably avoid that
by just adding a bunch
of floating black edges
that you can flip, or just
flip repeatedly until white
either wins, or
white doesn't win.
The decision question
is does white win?
Now we end up with a tie in
the case white doesn't win.
You can also change that by
having a long path of blacks.
And black is going to sit
there flipping, trying
to get to flipping their edge.
And the length of the
wire is exactly how long
it takes to fill in
all these things.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The reason why
they have that gadget there
at the end is you
need to set exactly
a certain number of them true?
Before black can, and so--
PROFESSOR: Oh.
I see.
Right.
Yeah.
That's a little more subtle.
OK.
Zero minutes remaining.
The same crossover works.
And you can also
build a protected OR.
Protected OR is where you never
have both of these coming in.
If you allow me the
notion of a free edge,
which is just floating there
and can be reversed whenever
you want, this is a white edge,
then this will act as a OR,
because this choice gadget can
only go one way or the other.
It's only one of the
inputs can actually
flip one of these edges, and
then the OR will just take it.
So we can build predicted ORs.
And then I have a bunch
of PSPACE hardness proofs
based on bounded
constraint logic,
but I suggest we wait
til Thursday to see this.
Because they're kind of fun.
And I'd rather spend a little
time going through the proof
details.
So you'll have to
wait in suspense
before we get to
Amazons, which is
a very fun-- you should
play Amazons meanwhile,
if you get a chance.
It's very fun if you
have a chessboard around.
And Konane, which is an ancient,
at least 300-year-old game
from Hawaii, and Cross Purposes,
which is a modern game.
These are all three
bounded two- player games.
And they're all PSPACE
complete by a reduction
from bounded two-player
constraint logic.
Cool.